so the first two episodes are fantastic
i'm sure you've heard that from everyone
coming into your
speed dating chamber um so i'm curious
though
how old do you think your character is
ah
well this is interesting because in
terms of time
um you know there is there's
there's eons i mean we're dealing with
eons here
in terms of uh how you know ren slayer
um you know in terms of the time that
she spans and and
um this is a really good question
because you know it's it's actually
you know we talk about it with mobius um
uh owen wilson's character in terms of
how how long they've known each other
and you know trying to
trying to fathom even they are not sure
because it's been you know
eons so um in terms of her age i mean
time as we say
is different in the tba uh so i don't
know that i've like
established a number i think that um as
i say
the normal rules of time are sort of
completely
um different in the time variance
authority so
we'll see yeah i'm trying to get a
straight answer out of people today and
i don't think anyone knows
um oh no one um
so i am curious what was it like finding
out that you might be getting recruited
in the mcu
uh was it something that you were super
excited about
yeah i mean you know i had a really cool
conversation with
kate herron initially our amazing
director
um who essentially pitched me over about
two hours all six episodes of the show
and what happened and how my characters
involved and you know it was a lot to
take in because you know the
the tva the you know the the time
sacred timeline all of these new
vocabularies that we are
in this world um was was a lot to take
in but i think
you know knowing how passionate kate was
you know the chance to work with tom who
i know has such an ownership of this
character over 10 years and
who you know i was actually at drama
school with so you know there's sort of
a full circle
uh time nature to that too um
so and also a new character you know um
ren slayer is is powerful and respected
and
you know a very different type of
character to anything i've played before
so
i was excited for that challenge um i
also think that
that's one of the reasons i think fans
will dig the show is because it's it's
showing a new part of the mcu that no
one has seen
but before i run out of time with you i
am a fan of the morning show
and so i'm just curious how has it been
going filming season two and
what can you tease for fans of hannah
well i don't know how much of season one
you've seen but i'm not in season two
of the morning show so um
i asked that because you never know with
flashbacks and other things
people can actually come back depending
on how the storylines go
this is very true i mean i i i can say
i'm about to start filming another apple
show with hello sunshine the same team
behind the morning show
but it's a completely different
completely different show and
um i'm excited to be leading that it's
called surface
i will i'll finish up with this question
i would imagine that when you went in to
make this series
loki that uh maybe you had some
preconceived ideas of how it would go
what it would be like working for marvel
how did making the series actually
compare to what you expected going in
what surprised you well you know
everything was kind of blown out of the
water in terms of
expectations certainly because we filmed
it in 2020
um we you know we started pre-pandemic
in february and
and you know i'd done about three days
before we had to go on hiatus and
which ended up being five months so um
so in terms of what you imagine any kind
of regular filmmaking experience it was
completely disrupted and
you know there was a lot of uncertainty
and obviously as everyone
went through in in that year um but then
coming back
you know and coming back with all with
masks and testing every
three times a week and social distancing
you know and you watch the show and you
can't really tell the circumstances
under which it was made but
it was we were breaking new ground there
you know we were one of the first shows
to get back up and running you know so
um
so i feel immense pride you know that
you you can watch a show like this and
it still feels cinematic and epic and
yet it was filmed you know
under brand new pandemic uh
circumstances so
um i'm really proud of everyone cannot
wait to finish this series up
have a fantastic day and good luck
filming whatever you're about to start
filming
thank you